what's more important
being a career woman or being a family
woman
is that a fair question um
no i don't think so i think it's about
how are you going to do that mix is
which is going to come first and i think
that that's what every woman struggles
to do because i thought about this and i
was like okay i need to establish myself
in a career so that i can take time off
have a baby and come back and still be
relevant a lot of women have a baby for
example a lot of women who study
marketing and then took three years off
to have their kid and raise it they come
back marketing has changed completely
trying to get a job in the same market
now there's two people younger right out
of college will take your job right from
you it's that decision as a woman it's
like okay which one do i do first or you
have a kid right when you've just come
out of college and then you jump in and
build yourself up and then don't have to
take breaks it's like how are you gonna
fit this puzzle it's just a puzzle for
women how what part fits when and where
it's and then the guy and when does that
come in that guy's kind of important
here
it's what you wanted of life your
partner has a huge tool to it right is
your partner always busy and working do
you need to raise a kid completely by
yourself does your partner not work as
much that allows you to work more it
literally depends on what you want but
you can create the life you want that's
what people don't realize but choosing
your life partner choosing the baby
daddy of your kid has a huge
huge effect
of the lifestyle you're going to live
but you guys have a very unique scenario
meaning you give a marketing example
right now but let's do a real life
example you guys are dancers you guys
need to you guys i need to look looking
good feeling good you know your body
needs to be right you can't just be
getting pregnant and then like you're
not it's
you guys getting pregnant and settling
down and having family
is a lot bigger deal than the marketing
girl i know but how do you balance that
as a dancer i know i know dancers that
have kids that still dance you said
career ending i think so no i know
dancers i know dancers that dance and
are still on tour
they're not touring that's what they
have no
dancing in general you're doing gigs
you're dancing you're making money
you're doing a lot of things my sister
was on miracon by the way oh yeah yeah
she danced with um
camacho my scissors dancer
so but it's it's it's a balance like you
can you can have what you want you just
got to create it for yourself
it's a balance of course you're i mean
you can't
be you know traveling the world um
if you want to be a present mother
that's another thing you can have a kid
and not be a present mother so be ceo of
a company traveling the world doing all
this stuff and have a nanny raising your
child right now nobody wants that but
that's another thing no there are people
that do want that yeah okay you get what
i'm trying to say but it's it goes back
to what i'm trying to say it's all what
you want
you make what you want so the bottom
line is what do you want
me personally
well i i lived my life
right i lived my dream of being a
professional dancer got off the road and
now i'm ready to
do what i want to do business-wise
allow myself space for whoever's
supposed to come
you know and then build from there but
i'm not gonna rush it i'm not just gonna
be like oh my god i'm this agent i don't
have kids yet okay this next guy come
you're not literally come you know like
well you're giving an eye roll what's
your no i'm agreeing
it's like for me the same way i feel
about kids the same way i feel about
tattoos i like them i like the idea of
them do i have any on my body no why
because nothing has
been enough of an impact for me to put
it on my body for the rest of my life no
person has come along that i was like
you know what you are it because all
marriage is nothing is that's not a big
deal anymore kid you have a kid with
somebody
you are they are with
the person that they chose to now have
to be a character a central character
for the rest of your life and that
affects the kids like so many people are
just having kids not worried about the
kids i know like this generation of kids
is like
insane
insane and so many that they used to
grow up without mother without mom and
daddy now they're growing up on a tablet
without mommy and daddy
you know what i mean like you can't be
selfish either and just bring kids into
this world because oh i i think i want
to be a mom no
you know like i can't wait to be a mom
but that doesn't mean i'm going to go
right now
no i can't wait listen oh yeah
what's the latest jenny the latest you
could see yourself having your first
child latest god's timing you don't have
a number in mind no 30
40.
whatever happens stop it you're not
going to wait till you're 40. whatever
happens i don't know um
it's like do you want to be an old mom
but somebody who lived their life or be
a young mom and then
and then we chose to live our lives
before we have kids when we get our kids
we're not living vicariously through our
kids i don't want to travel with my kids
and see the world
i've traveled the world now and i'm
going to keep traveling i love traveling
i go everywhere by myself solo traveling
i love it and i want to do it now not
when i have a kid and dragging them and
paying a thousand dollar ticket to take
them to paris and a trip they'll never
remember [ __ ] that damn by the way i
know for a fact that there's uh by the
way eric if there's any comments
there's so she said i started having
kids at 16 by 24 i had four kids now i'm
back and have a business it's not that
deep unless you live in miami there's uh
these are hollow topics is what she said
these are hollow topics yeah and then um
let's see then sergio said fact being
raised by a mexican household that was
raised to get you know to get married
have kids and have a house by 20. yeah
yeah
interesting so do you have a number in
mind when you would want to have a kid
like latest yes
probably like 35 35. there's a number
there yeah i think so if i want to have
kids i don't know if i do really yeah i
don't know oh no i definitely want to
have kids
[Music]